I'm not sure the words have been
invented
to describe what it's like to be black
in America
[Music]
I used to think that I had a strategy
right is keep the voice calm they'd be
like hey I am now reaching for my wallet
my keys are on the roof my hands are up
officer walking them step by step and
that's still wasn't enough to keep it
alive as an adult black male living in
this country my biggest fear now is
leaving work leaving the apartment
wherever walking down the sidewalk
making eye contact with a white police
officer who takes it as a threat getting
out of his squad car and then unloading
his entire clip into my chest because I
quote-unquote threatened him somehow
like thinking about just situations that
I've been involved in in terms of police
and like how I'm very thankful that it
didn't go the way that you know Sandra
Bland's went or Alton Stirling Eric
Gardner you know Oscar Grant I think
about these people and how it didn't end
up that way
but it ended up in a different way where
it embedded in me that I'm not safe
because of my skin color
[Music]
and my initial feeling was just numbness
at some point when there was a whole
string of these occurrences happening I
started to become numb to it and now I'm
like numb to being numb my initial
reaction after hearing what the second
one was just numb like okay again and I
think that's the saddest part is that
I'm just numb to it I feel uh
disassociated like this weird feeling
were like I I feel like I'm watching
myself go through everything honestly my
first I was like this can't be real so I
didn't believe it
it was unbelievable and the fact that it
wasn't unbelievable it's getting crazy
and crazier that people are able to
ignore it when I first saw it I'd I
don't know I just started a house
freaking out I just started crying I
can't even describe how I'm feeling as
being sad it's more so angry and
exhausted it's just hard it's getting to
the point where it's hard to even keep
up because it's happening so frequently
how many times does have to happen for
like something else to happen I don't
know I really don't know [ __ ] do y'all
because I really don't know they think
they can keep getting away with this
because they are getting away with it
they are afraid of us we're not given
the benefit of the doubt because they
assume that we're going to act a certain
way I think they look at dogs as people
more than they look at black people as
people
absolutely 100% because any emotion for
a black male happiness sadness you know
it's almost too much uh for the people
around you I feel like I have to put on
a face like if I'm around my friends and
if they say something that like could be
like could be stepping on the toes of
like offending me and then I would feel
bad that I was offended we as people
have to be strong times too
wrong times three because we have to be
programmed to either not feel a certain
way when things happen and carry on as
if everything is okay when it clearly
it's not or we have to be able to you
know muzzle that emotion
and save it for a more appropriate time
or a more appropriate environment
Alton Sterling's son was crying on
national television and his mom sat
there and continued to talk about how
wrong and how out of line his death was
and I saw someone say a white woman say
if I was her I would stop and console
him and it was just a reminder to me
that they don't live in a world that we
live in and now it was hard to like
explain to her that she can't she's
balancing now being a mom and a father
and consoling her son and dealing with
her own emotions like we don't have a
choice because we can't we don't have
ownership of our own lives and that's
[ __ ] up selfish it does they're
cowards you're inhumane I mean the one
word that comes to mind is just ruthless
frightened scared small even with all
the equipment on you know the badge the
whole force behind them like why are you
so scared where is your empathy where is
your sympathy where are those human
qualities you have no connection to be
able to do that to someone so quickly
they are inhumane I don't even consider
the heat they're not humans anymore as
far as I'm concerned those are the ones
who were not human human beings have the
potential to do so much great in this
world I just I feel like we have the
potential to be so much greater and
better and higher than what we are
currently like if we could just come to
a consensus like as America to just be
like this is really [ __ ] up and as
white people as Asians as
is like Native Americans as everybody we
can just come together and agree this is
really [ __ ] up the way this country
was built it wasn't in our favor it
still isn't in our favor and it's not
going to change until systematically
from like the very very root there's
restructuring
[Music]
[Music]